let's talk to our caller from the eight
five zero area code eight five zero
what's your name where are you calling
from oh hey David hey my name is James
I'm from middle-of-nowhere Florida hey
James what's going on
wait a second what are you on are you
from the Pensacola area all right yeah
around there yeah okay I love that area
well it's no it's a small town near
there yeah it's not really big okay
maybe that's Pensacola school no you
wouldn't but I have a quote I have a
question okay why aren't people marching
through the streets calling for Trump's
impeachment I mean right yes American
this is an easy one this is an easy one
we dealt with this actually earlier in
the week here's the reason why the
system that benefits from people not
marching in the streets is the same
system that prevents people from
marching in the streets and what I mean
by that is when you have stagnant wages
for the bottom 50% when you have some
people working two or three jobs when
you have people who can't afford to miss
a day of work or who risk getting fired
if they miss a day of work
they can't go march in the streets and
this is what perpetuates the system that
makes sense yeah it's sad that that
makes a lot of sense it's an employee
bad yeah I mean but yeah but you look at
like Hong Kong Russia Puerto Rico
there's like people like crowding the
Capitals
you know protesting you know there's a
not in America there's this interesting
thing where I tend to disagree with the
burn it all down to build it back up
thing that some people agree with I'm
okay with incrementalism in general but
there is a reality that when things get
so bad that people don't even have a job
to cling to then all of a sudden they
might be more ready to go march in the
streets which is a sad reality sometimes
things have to get even worse so that
people
no longer feel like there's any downside
to just bailing on whatever they're
doing and going to march in the streets
we're not really there yet for the
majority of Americans because so many
people they're hanging by a thread but
they are hanging on and that that's just
the dynamic that's inherent to our
system so it'll take something like
another economic crash it may for
something like that happened it may yeah
I don't know that makes sense yeah James
appreciate thank all appreciate talking
to you man have a good day you too
take care